[Applause]
he said to him he said them he said them
he said them he said he
it's turned out to be a great life they
like comment me wrong go home
and look at what I have as a gift
singer actor activist Harry Belafonte
told E.T he wanted to use his Fame to
make a difference I've considered myself
very fortunate my family my wife
thanks Mrs Dr Martin Luther King the way
the public has supported me all through
the years
as an artist in my lifetime I was born
in 1927 so I was a depression baby I
watched us go through the Second World
War I was in the United States Navy
during that war
after working as a janitor's assistant
Harry's success in music led to Broadway
appearances and groundbreaking movies
like Carmen Jones and Island in the Sun
as you're looking for something real
you're not lost
Belafonte's music had its biggest
audience in the movie Beetlejuice
[Music]
in the dinner scene and at the end when
Winona Ryder flies and dances
[Music]
but no doubt these were bellefonte's
proudest moments
[Music]
working tirelessly for civil rights
organizing marches donating money and
inspiring activists great thing
and there are millions on the way
we saw the injustices of our day and we
stepped to the table I have a moral
obligation to do what one can do to make
a difference
this is behind the scenes footage of one
of Belafonte's final roles where art
imitated life Harry played civil rights
leader Jerome Taylor in the movie Black
klansman that's why
we're here today
the neighbors
black power
still looking at very young what is your
secret aggravation
with who and what life
Harry was married three times and had
four children including the actress
Sherry Belafonte his lifelong fight for
justice was honored by his peers in 2014
when he received the gene hirschholt
humanitarian award
I really wish I could be around
for the rest of this century
see what Hollywood does
with the rest of the century well for me
it doesn't get any better than this my
peers have stepped to the plate and said
job well done and I think that alone was
worth the whole journey
in 2021 the French ambassador to the U.S
awarded Belafonte the title of Night of
the Legion of Honor the following year
he was inducted into the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame Harry who did not attend
was given the early influence award
producers acknowledged that he was not a
rock and roll singer but delivered the
anger and agitation that at its best are
what rock and roll promises he was able
to do something for us that not only our
race benefited from but the whole world
benefited from and continues to benefit
from today
[Music]
thank you